there may be three things you probably
fear reading about these days the
outcome of your college midterm exams
the daily news and your gas and electric
bill for the first two nothing to say
sorry it happens as for the rising bills
yes that happens too but for specific
reasons and you're not too wrong when we
talk about gas and electricity we are
referring to what provides us with a
basic standard of living heating hot
water electricity and gas for cooking in
short your domestic hearth not to
mention of course those factories who
cannot work without gas and electricity
let's start with the harsh reality the
entire european union is not
self-sufficient in energy which means a
dense network of imports of course if
norway was an eu country we might
consider it an anomaly over there they
produce plenty of gas 101 billion cubic
meters of gas in 2012 which they don't
even use they only make do with 4
billion since they managed to get by
with hydroelectricity
and burning churches in fact in 2012
they exported something like 110 billion
cubic meters of gas there's actually a
european champion for gas production or
rather there was we're talking about the
netherlands which a decade ago was
around 70 billion cubic meters of gas
produced there's a small problem however
a bit like the dwarves of moria the
dutch have dug too deep causing seismic
damage related to drilling the large
growing implant will close soon but the
production has already been drastically
reduced down to 20 billion cubic meters
and if there is a fourth thing you would
absolutely not want to see this is the
map of the gas pipelines that cross the
old continent where and how do these
billions of cubic meters of gas arrive
in the homes of us europeans
non-european natural gas comes for 43.9
percent from russia 19.9 from norway
11.9 percent from algeria 5.5
from uk 5 from the us and a remaining
13.8 percent from other countries such
as azerbaijan qatar libya nigeria
trinidad and tobago these are the main
countries that extract and sell their
gas to us today both in natural form and
lng there is the liquefied gas the
undisputed queen or rather the serena is
russia much of the gas exported to the
old continent is extracted from the
fields of the yamal peninsula in
northwestern siberia it's here that we
find the famous taps more precisely near
the pleasant town of novi urangoy and
here the mass begins from novi orengoy
the northern lights pipeline starts and
proceeds unhindered to the town of
tordok northwest of moscow here two
things happen the pipeline continues
towards belarus on the smallinsk minsk
directive where it splits one part
continues north towards lithuania and
then kaliningrad and another path to the
south towards western ukraine at tarzok
the northern lights pipeline also joins
a second pipeline the yama europe which
passes through minsk and poland to the
german border at libous where it joins
the german jagal system the urangoy
pomari utzgorod known as the brotherhood
also departs from navi urangoy with a 4
400 kilometer long snake that crosses
ukraine and reaches the slovakian border
in parallel with the soyuz which departs
to the south from oremburg on the one
hand there's belarus through which the
gas that fits germany and therefore
northwestern europe passes and on the
other side there's ukraine the gateway
through which the traffic for balkan and
southern europe flows but there's more
yep in fact a branch of the brotherhood
flows to novopskov in the luhansk
people's republic from which it then
reconnects to the ukrainian network up
to kiev crushing basically the whole
country but let's pretend that in donbas
everything is regular and no war is
going on there are in fact other russian
routes that reach europe by passing
ukraine and belarus well europe up to a
certain point if we talk about the turks
stream pipeline which from anapa on the
shores of the black sea with a
privileged view on crimea reaches turkey
atipsa where it evolves into torque
stream 2 running up the continent up to
hungary the same applies to the blue
stream which crosses the black sea from
izobilny plant to reach ankara directly
the italian corridor is really
interesting especially for us italians
since we
rely on russian gas for about 40 percent
we are talking about the trans-adriatic
gas pipeline the t-a-p active since the
end of 2012 that will connect italy more
precisely the receiving terminal of
meladuno in napoleon straight to the
rich field of shahadanis in azerbaijan
on the coast of the caspian sea the tap
passes through albania and crosses greek
macedonia to kipoy on the turkish border
there it connects to tanap the
trans-anatolian pipeline all the way to
georgia where it finally attaches to the
south caucasian pipeline in 2021 seven
billion cubic meters passed through
maladuna but we're not done with russia
yet we need to talk about node stream
active since 2011 north stream creates a
direct supply line between wieberg in
russia and grieves world in germany
passing under the baltic sea attaching
to the grace of its wieberg pipeline
north stream supplies some of the gas
that passes through the northern lights
something like 55 billion cubic meters
per year can pass through north stream
although some european sanctions on gas
prom have reduced its actual capacity by
half what's the deal let's just build
another one right in september the
controversial project of nordstrom 2 was
completed an almost parallel pipeline
which instead of eborg it connects to us
luge and that would double the direct
supply capacity of germany from russia
with around 110 billion cubic meters if
all goes well and why should anything
ever go wrong well the list of views
against the nord stream 2 is quite long
and then we should also consider that
the nordstrom 2 company based in
switzerland went bankrupt day before
yesterday
thank you sanctions first of all the
project contradicts the common energy
policy that the european union is trying
to pursue diversifying its supplies to
free itself from russian dependence
russia on the contrary would see in the
potential of north stream 1 and 2 an
alternative channel to the compulsory
steps of belarus and especially ukraine
this would offer moscow a fearsome
weapon of blackmail and influence on its
neighbors and it's not only ukraine
that's involved because slovakia hungary
romania poland are all in this game
putin could knock on kiev's door and
impose his conditions otherwise no more
gas through ukraine because me russia
can bring it straight to germany
diversification doesn't mean simply
changing course but finding other
supplies however there's another detail
which is rather disturbing the company
that will operate the new pipeline north
stream 2 agi based in switzerland is
totally owned by guests from
international projects llc a branch of
gas from itself nordstrom 2 agi is all
that remains of the joint venture formed
by in addition to gazprom eon shell
winter shoal omv and ng a consort
simulator blocked by the polish
antitrust authorities these former
partners are now outside north stream 2
agi but they have given substantial
amounts of money as sponsors the
management of north stream 2 by gas
promote in addition to giving even more
centrality to russia would go against
the european energy policies that
prevent suppliers from controlling the
energy transmission networks and one of
the first nations to risk the
consequences of nordstrom 2 is poland
but poland has already run for cover yes
because fortunately for europe next to
the monopolized baltic sea there's
another sea rich in deposits the north
sea on this year work should begin on
the baltic pipeline a pipeline that will
connect the northern coasts of poland to
the heart of the northern sea passing
through denmark and attaching itself to
the network with which norway supplies
western europe and the united kingdom
and here we come to our two not too much
european country what the uk and norway
have done in the north sea may at first
seem like a complete mess the north sea
is full of gas fields that the two
countries have long shared but norway
also has reached deposits close to the
arctic in the waters north of trondheim
as we have seen norway exports almost
all of the gas it extracts and pipelines
to the uk depart from the arctic such as
the longlead pipeline to loftus on the
coast of north yorkshire and the
parallel ormond lange field easington
pipeline the coasts between bergen and
stavanger represent a real hub where gas
extracted from the northern north sea
and the arctic is redirected to
continental europe through pipelines
such as z-pipe in belgium or euro pipe 2
which connects stavanger to the dutch
coast the netherlands and belgium are
however largely supplied by the many
norwegian extraction sites located in
the south waters of the north sea and
then there's the united kingdom which
has some problems it extracts plenty of
gas compared to the european average in
2012 it was about 40 billion cubic
meters but it consumed almost twice as
much 72 billion according to eurostat
the biggest issue however is the lack of
an adequate storage network this is why
uk has few supplies this is also due to
the shutdown of the rough plant in 1217
which alone for 30 years accounted for
70 percent of the country's storage
capacity
in any case there are three main hubs
towards which the flows of british gas
and imported quotas from norway are
condensed aberdeen north yorkshire and
backton in north norfolk from these
three nodal points the uk national
network is supplied this includes as
well the three main terminals from which
lng is exported and imported by sea
milford haven in wales the grain lng
terminal on the island of grain in kent
and in middlesbrough for many people lng
is a solution to the excessive
dependence on russian gas a solution
that is certainly more expensive than
transportation by pipelines but which is
more adaptable and no longer bound by
geographical proximity but it does not
have only positive aspects yeah sure
it's fine to replace russia and north
stream but the arrival of ships loaded
with lng from the us also has
repercussions on the homeless norwegian
exporters if the russian pipeline policy
is threatening the european geopolitical
and economic balance the american
involvement is no less in the lng roots
not only the united states are involved
of course spanish ports marseille
rotterdam athens these are the main
destinations of lng coming from qatar
nigeria and trinidad and tobago even we
italians so thirsty for gas have
important lng import terminals in la
spezia rivorno and in the adriatic sea
adriatic sea which is well supplied with
fields that are not much exploited by
our workforce after all it looks really
awful to go to the sea and see the
italian floating stations on the horizon
much better the croatian ones right we
italians have also another interesting
route in the mediterranean sea in the
heart of the algerian desert lies the
largest african gas field hasermel this
gas oasis is the starting point for
three very important gas pipelines for
southern europe on the one hand there
are the two macgrab europe and mad guts
pipeline which cross morocco and the
mediterranean to supply spain on the
other hand the trans-mediterranean
pipeline which crosses tunisia and
arrives in sicily at mazar del value and
then climbs the entire peninsula as far
as slovenia from libya on the tripoli
gela route comes the green stream
there's also the interesting project of
galaxy gas pipeline algeria sardinia
italy that from the algerian gulf of
anaba should bring gas to sardinia and
from there to tuscany but the southern
route doesn't end in africa there has
been talk for some years of a gas
pipeline the east med which from the
fields in the eastern mediterranean sea
between cyprus and israel should run to
greece between crete and the peloponnese
and then it should enter our adriatic
sea through the poseidon pipeline up to
all toronto erdogan permitting the turks
have different views on the cyprus
fields as well as a different
understanding of exclusive economic
zones in the mediterranean sea so we
have come to the end of this exciting
trip up and down europe exciting rising
bills could be a rather long lasting
reality if certain measures are not
taken but i'm certainly not the best
person to explain them to you i'll leave
you some links in the description so you
can have a look at the european gas
pipeline mess this video could have been
much worse in the meantime i just say
thank you for listening to me until the
end and see you next time ciao